if you didn't have this 90-day  you know limit that you have  a year to decide if you're gonna get  married  the question i have is would you really  end up getting married at all  no  i'll wait till  we have more time and figure things out  but that's hypothetically speaking and  i don't have that time  my wish upon wish is that you guys just  postpone this  and if it's something that you guys  continue to want to do  in six months or a year you re-evaluate  this and decide if you want to still be  married  debris is  saying that he would not get married to  miona if this 90-day clock wasn't there  right  and he's not ready to get married yet so  i want him to listen to himself  right i think part of what is  really  keeping him in this decision to get  married is concern about the blowback  from miona  that really pains me to say because i  want to be optimistic  but that does not seem like it's going  to be healthy in a marriage  [Music]  you